he is part of the ESPN NFL draft
extravaganza he will be a competitor of
mine and a partner of mine we're all
partnered together in the NFL world to
try and make the draft as big as
possible so that's the world of the NFL
competitors and partners together we're
all family is that right I think so Todd
McShea here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you talking good looking forward to
getting down there what's it like tell
me it's it's a little partly cloudy
actually you know what I'm gonna see
partly sunny Oh positive you know have
fun cuz I'm standing I'm standing it
yeah and it's it's it's building you
could see you could you could feel it in
me in the town it's gonna be gonna be a
little bit like Philly it sounds like
just crazy I mean Broadway is gonna be
totally transformed and if the weather's
nice it's going to be lit it's gonna be
fantastic and the fans here are all
fired up you can you can sense that
they're fired up to have a major
big-time National Football League event
like this the off season Superbowl in a
way they're fired up they're excited so
I'm excited to have you here on the
phone line right now what the hell's
going on with calamari always in the
Cardinals is the only way I put it I
mean it's it's the linchpin right of the
night and what's happening horses it's
one of the biggest stories in the
history of the NFL Draft if you think
about it I mean he'll be the first
quarterback be the first player to ever
be drafted in the first round of Major
League Baseball and the NFL we didn't
even think he was going to be in this
graph a few months ago I talked to
Scouts in October when I was covering
two oklahoma games back-to-back talked
to scout area scouts and in the you know
the southeast southwest area and they
said they weren't even looking at him I
remember distinctly one of the texts
saying you know what he's either going
back to school or he's going to play
Major League Baseball so if it goes back
to school to play football next year
I'll deal with him next year I mean so
this is he's the biggest story of this
year's draft there's no question
ecstatically it makes a ton of sense
that he would be the the pick for Kliff
Kingsbury
I mean cliff was the starting
quarterback Lincoln Riley was his backup
at Texas Tech they've been around the
same system
they've morphed it into different things
and certainly Lincoln has taken it to a
different area and has advanced it more
to be quite honest with you but the
verbage is still somewhat the same the
the background is the same and even he
just makes a lot of sense for them but
you've got to be able to create Rosen
and I also go back to this too when they
hired him I think it was January 8th we
didn't know if Tyler was going to be in
this draft where although I mean he was
on your show I think that the awkward
interviews at the Super Bowl not knowing
Sinnott of Lee if he was gonna play
baseball or football so when Arizona
hired cliff they hired him with the
mindset that Rosen was going to be the
quarterback moving forward and now all
of a sudden it's just you know almost
immediate shift towards when we got to
the combine in late February so it won't
shock me if he's not the first overall
pick but I still think there's a better
than 80% chance that he's that Kyler
Murray is the first overall pick and we
probably won't know what happens with
Josh Rosen until they get on the clock
or maybe maybe after yeah I think that
that's that's a valid assessment that
that Rosen is definitely part of this
equation when you talk about the
evaluation of Murray and in that regard
if they if they don't take Murray then
they have they have messed with the mind
of Josh Rosen for the first two three
months of the Kliff Kingsbury
administration there and that's the
thing that I find odd about Murray not
being the first overall pick in this
draft and I know that part of the
narrative has been driven by the media
and I understand that the Cardinals
can't do anything about it without the
with the exception of Stevie I'm not
saying that Rosen's the quarterback for
now or coming out and basically saying
we're not taking them which obviously
wouldn't be the smart thing to do when
you're trying to be open for business
with the first overall selection so this
whole thing is so unique I can't
remember a situation like this where a
team has an opportunity to take somebody
that's such an outlier as the first
overall pick in the draft after having
selected a quarterback
in the first round the previous year and
they're having to offload them or make
nice with him it's crazy it is crazy and
either either they have messed with his
mind for the last couple of several
months or that interview that he
recently been through Josh Rosen he's a
great actor because it clearly appears
that he is he doesn't know he thinks
it's up in the air what's going to
happen and no one's really communicating
with him you know what the future holds
in Arizona so it could in to your point
to do that to your starting quarterback
that all of a sudden if they go in a
different direction hey we're all in
let's go
plus he's a champ to them I mean it the
whole thing is really bizarre the
building right now I know he's there
today is when they were going to be
having some more offseason activities
and by the way he does not know that's
not an acting job and the video
referring to is that Sports Illustrated
video that is a fascinating watch for
anybody that wants to get some access to
a young kid trying to figure things out
or it's the worst ever Breaking Bad
sequel I've ever seen it was really with
the RV in the desert you know and Josh
Rosen on top of the RV it's the whole
thing is is nuts so after that I'm
assuming Nick VOSA is first off the
board in a name that's not Cuyler Murray
would you agree with that assessment yes
and I think I think part of all of this
could be you know that seems like a lot
of people are starting to come out and
say this week all about social or I have
a source it could just be Arizona trying
to get San Francisco to come up to
number one to take Bosa which I don't
know it will be I hear you I hear you
it's its event so then again potentially
alienating rosin or or or running the
risk of not getting Murray I guess
you're right I guess it's all that this
gambit they'd still take Murray it's you
just saying agreement basically there
yeah coming up so long to get Bosa
and we
have offers for trades to move out what
is what you would be selling if you're
Steve I'm the general manager of Arizona
so you know we have offers to move back
if you guys want to come up and make
sure you get both and the other team
doesn't come up to get them looking for
and and the the interesting name that I
keep hearing that is a fast riser or is
the apple of so many people's eyes as Ed
Oliver from Houston I hear the phrases
like unicorn freak and then I also hear
well he's not Aaron Donald where do you
stand on him and where do you think he
might go there's one there's one aaron
donald in the world and that's it
but but i but he can be a better more
productive pass rusher than he was at
least you know people have been talking
about it and it's true using him at nose
tackle didn't make a whole lot of sense
he's played at about two hundred and
seventy two pounds and when you're
playing over the over the center you've
got the center to deal with and then i
go in on both sides now if you move into
the three technique meaning lining up on
the outside shoulder you think of Donald
and warren sapp and all the great three
techniques and just let him he's got
unique initial burst off the ball and
some shock in his hands and power for
her guy his size let him get up field
stress the offensive lineman and and
then work on his hands and don't become
a better finisher I I think he's got a
chance to be a great player in the NFL
and maybe a more productive player in
the NFL if used properly and I think
some teams are seeing that Greg Williams
you know I know he's saying he's staying
with the three-four it's a hybrid system
he's had three techniques with great
quickness before and I think that I
think for the Jets at three it would
make some sense I think it Oakland for
could make some sense Tampa Bay is a
possibility the Giants are a possibility
so I I really don't see him getting out
of the top six picks when it's all said
and done I mean we've got fossa
obviously tyler murray to go number one
you got quentin Williams defensive
tackle from Alabama who's going to be a
top five pick Josh Allen's Kentucky the
edge rusher
three four outside linebacker is going
to be very likely a top five pick and
then I think Devon white the off the
ball linebacker from from LSU
is the other guy that you have to factor
in but I think ed Oliver is in that
equation in terms of the top six seven
picks in this year's draft and then the
last one for you Todd McShane I've got
obviously if Murray goes number one
overall or doesn't let's say he doesn't
that'd be obviously the biggest surprise
of the draft then then the next surprise
of the draft would be a team that takes
a quarterback we're not expecting who
might that team be from what you're
hearing right now two days before the
draft begins such a mess rich I mean
last year we didn't know I didn't know
the Baker was going to be the pick of of
Cleveland but we knew the four
quarterbacks or gonna go somewhere in
the top ten twelve or so picks and we
knew that we knew the Cleveland was
going to take one where the Jets had
already moved up to get one the Giants
were a question mark but either it was
going to be shaken or a quarterback and
then we had Buffalo Arizona and a couple
other teams over possibility this year
there's really if you exclude Arizona
because technically just on paper they
don't need a quarterback because they
create it up to ten to get Josh Rosen
last year so if you exclude Arizona of
the first nine teams the Giants are the
only one sitting at six that really need
a quarterback and they're the ones
telling everyone in the week telling
everyone that they can hear that they're
not going to take a quarterback at six
so that's where it gets interesting
I don't think Denver is going to take
one at ten I think Cincinnati could if
the right guys there I think maybe
Dwayne Haskins is the possibility I
actually don't think Miami's going to
take the quarterback 213 unless maybe
you know if Tyler was somehow to
possibly fall thirteen I think Haskins
makes the most sense at Washington at
fifteen and maybe they move up to go get
a guy and then everyone keeps saying
Daniel Jones for the Giants at seventeen
or the Giants could move up a few spots
we'll see I think it's a big reach I've
you know I've stated it I think he's a
good player but I think he's a great
backup who could be a starter but I just
those guys I like to draft on day two so
to me there are three first-round
quarterbacks in this year's class and
those are the team's really between 10
and 17 that I think are the most light
to make a move ask make sure the poll
question before we send him on and uh
until his dad walk me all right Todd
what's the biggest surprise in recent
NFL draft history biggest surprise Mario
Williams goes number one in O six Baker
Mayfield goes number one last year Tebow
Tebow goes in the first round in 2010
Aaron Rodgers falls all the way down to
24 in 2005 or that crazy Laremy Tunsil
gas mask video from 2016 Tebow blew my
mind
I'll be honest I didn't think there was
a shot Tebow I mean the last three I
think are all legitimate answers but
Tebow go in the first round absolutely
stunning
all it takes is one man that's all it
takes and one and McDaniels is reunited
with the picky chose before Tebow
Demaryius Thomas right now it's amazing
how those things happen
I got Marquis Brown coming in studio
tell me about him real quick before he
walks in here what is the most
functional speed I think I've ever
evaluated a wide receiver come on chill
meaning like the quickness speed being
being able to get in and out of breaks I
know he didn't run a 40-yard dash I know
he's 166 pounds I know he's coming off
the list ranked injury I would take that
dude in the top 15 and I would sleep
really well on Thursday night no kidding
yeah and I know he's gonna fall he's
gonna go into 20s probably that's what
everyone's saying it that's fine I'm
just saying when when we look back on it
people are going to especially today's
league getting in space explosiveness
playmakers people are gonna look back
and say what were we thinking we're way
over over reacted to to a foot injury
and to 166 pounds if to play so you
think the Steelers might take Antonio's
cousin to replace him what do you think
probably not Thursday night man I would
love that
hello I try man I'm trying I'm trying -
hey
I'll see you national I'll see you when
you get down here just let me know when
your banks that's a you bet that's Tom
McShea vsp and McShea 13 is his twitter
handle for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune
- audience Channel - 39 on DirecTV for
free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app